we don't know oh no no no fur and we're
gonna play another game of stand-up
comedian poker what the [ __ ] we call it
what this today is Jay Lawson whose
money is that Felipe Esparza rough tough
[ __ ] it baby down Morgan Murphy I'm not
losing cuz I'm drinking I'm drinking
because I'm losing and earthquake aka
Nathaniel strongly pokus not a sport are
you gonna call this a sport - I mean I
mean people do we have to make you feel
like they're athletic you just sitting
there getting fatter
alright so we're gonna play hold them
there on the exit hole oh yeah you know
play it yeah all right on TV yeah all
right earthquake hey or nah but I fine
I'm quick bar you know sort of tea so
there's gonna be white sir one greens or
two reds or fives
wait black g10 white we don't get a lot
of people read a lot of the blacks but
they're very valuable
well bet you one and two small one big -
so you're big you have to put two in
you're the big blind you have to put
anything in yet birth everyone's gonna
get two cards and then we're all gonna
take a look at our cards Bobby Lee is
not here so we can all relax one he
looks - 510 is everyone who wants to
stay I'm in for that do you want to play
this hand if you do you need to put in
one more one of the value yeah I just $1
for the white mix to go over here it's a
nice run
these are you twos these are five these
are ten why's everybody with hair stay
on this thing all right pair of deuces
and what's gonna happen is you bet first
if you want to bet if you you know you
could say oh I bet a couple bucks or I
wouldn't do that and then it goes to
Morgan if Morgan wants to be in if she
wants to fool
I mean I'm gonna not be in Morgan's oh
[ __ ] I'm getting fur what
that's it I can do what could you have
you get two pairs Bluff
that's big it's the first hand she's
doing it it's a it's are you gonna go in
system mental or the black one word
that's we're at 10:10 well usually you
wait for the person before you but now
that I know that you're going in I'll
fold wait how can you do that you were
supposed to go before healing I know I
guess like okay yeah he's like the mad
saw him fit and then he was like you
gotta get a little rhythm going huh I'm
up now you're out
yeah what's your I had four of a kind
plus the two pair that's yeah you were
working huh you were working on a four
of a kind of economy focus on all the
other colors Donald Trump lives right
there I know try to intimidate people
think it Philippe as far as it was there
you know Mexican do it I build a wall
like Trump right make him a little
nervous really he like to build it like
a wall no seam no [ __ ] count your
money so I like to mix them all up but
fellow that's 25 that's 100 pretty I
like my [ __ ] to be like my room messy
only I know what my drawers is that I
could barely keep track about a value of
every champ saw I was confused just
consistently needing to be reminded of
the worth of each chip on every hand for
hours when you go to the bank do you
want the teller account someone has to
count otherwise what do what do we have
anarchy yeah so he put in two and he
raised it one that's right I'm gonna
fall very conservative Jimmy yeah a
little mr. Rogers sweater all his shiny
gonna go with this one all day when you
play he has no idea what he's doing he's
already raised and so I'm just like who
knew enough to wear sunglasses there
these a little [ __ ] yeah over here
though not in your pile dude you like
Jack Nicholson know what for the
Cuckoo's Nest right now just explaining
everything I love that I'll take that
all day Shatner William Jack alright
let's go three just lay him out however
you want there was something about you
tricking him early on that makes me want
to least beat you that's fine but I was
just doing it to like let him know like
hey see what happens your approval am I
supposed to do something yeah I'm the
war but that's all I told you remind me
cuz I'm not you want to make a bet you
can check or bet I want to bet okay then
bet I want to bet a green one too two of
them no that's two dollars oh yes sorry
hey I'm out getting rid of my wife folks
where do you get all those yeah what
happened over there don't worry about it
that's the house that's the house he's
full of [ __ ] cuz he should have just put
one black chip in there buddy
he's trying to make it look bigger you
get rid of white people like it's a
plague all right Felipe's in didn't hit
the river
maybe it's straight seven nine ten Jack
something gotta eat Jack in their hand
hey maybe you could just let people play
yeah maybe I could quit quit trying to
be a [ __ ] weatherman Morgan HX sorry
to earthquake he went red to green now
he's going over to white you guys know
what he's doing just keep an eye on this
giant stack of mystery how many of those
ten more dollars oh I'm out oh no no
Morgan you gotta go in we got to all see
what he has I know about this for the
table this is I mean this is gonna be
pathetic and see that it's something he
would trust his black fronts to put him
out there and he is how many sacrifice
one blanket that's all I'm black ship
alright watch that's how it's done right
but this is the move where now people on
the internet are gonna go like oh [ __ ]
no matter what you do it what you got
well you both flip in what you got same
time right let's see two nines Terry's
got two pair of Hobbiton I'm not gonna
race it I just don't feel comfortable
with all those chips being over that we
don't know what they're for next to me
would you be more comfortable exactly
I'd be more comfortable if they were
right here
what's the tell I like Dave Attell the
good thing about reading the table when
you're playing with comedians is that
you already know that everybody is in
their own head Jay cares about Jay
Philippe cares about a flea pay bill
care developer okay so you know where
everybody is just hos
I'm gonna read a hoe now I think in life
I'm very good at reading people I'm also
like one of these I think man is
innately good not man is innately bad so
I give everyone the benefit the doubt
Chang Larsen has a couple of tells ain't
got a satisfied look on his face at one
point I was just like I knew if someone
had a bad hand it's a drop like a good
hat is like
[Music]
quake your quake I'm gone some people
call you quake who gave you earthquake
tell me you did well I did because my
real name is nathaniel strowman oh yeah
that's quick close to the hey nice that
looks awful what the hell is that car a
joke that's their burn that's something
I don't like it's so close to sorry now
you know I feel about the chips no that
ain't the same white Esmond this racial
since Bobby Lee was here accused sister
telling agent jokes and all that all a
big distraction his whole thing is a
conspiracy when he's going back there
and looking on the monitor see we can
work the truck really I cheated he did
vote for trumpeting Bobby yeah he liked
his hair is that a weave that he has
would you think is that more like a
toupee he visually just so surgery each
one in whoo
Trump himself his daughter say that
one-time surgically putting each one in
there it hurt and it looks like ice work
in a dental office and this dentist that
I worked with he needed a filling mm-hmm
and he just didn't trust out a dentist
and I stood there and I watched he did
his own tooth like he knew himself oh
yeah I was laughing my ass off dude he
had me hold the mirror I he was sitting
I was dying laughing it was like the
ultimate Do It Yourself job Wow
and he did I guess you're just for
socializing with you you can't really
arise what are you hiding from you got
any loss why can't you just be yourself
all right what's what's what am I doing
here whatever you want to bet three
three Whitey's yeah give it boom I'm
sorry you guys you know [ __ ] this
industry like two four six eight ten
I wish it was I wish that's what a
straight was no it's two three four five
yeah
is there a name for that hand two's your
folder okay all right what am I gonna
just pay three bucks to see what you got
I'll pay three bucks for it
I got a king well I got nothing
[Applause]
oh wait can I deal forum if makes me
drink whiskey
hey Morgan you want Redbush is that what
it is
swear to god you want vodka yes please
I've never seen anything like this this
little house in the Prairie hump paw
making you a vodka my best skill is the
first third of the game that's how long
I've ever been able to give a [ __ ] about
anything and I have the grades in high
school to back that up I crushed it in
September right through mid-october
I go into like a little boy who's lost
but little by little man I'm reading
everybody else's eyes I'm checking the
way they look I don't think I have a
good hand then think how can I
manipulate everyone around me into
believing otherwise and I'm okay losing
poker and not being a sociopath I'm okay
with that combination there was not one
impressive skill or talent outside our
comedic sensibilities that I saw at all
today I'll [ __ ] them up in some space
next game we need a space or tongue many
black families done broke up for tongue
they really think black families broke
up because chick had a kid in the father
just left no more black family has been
broke up over tongue in Spain's a lot of
families we don't speak no more these
the games that broke up more than racism
yes
wait who's even I don't even know who's
sir here it is alright smalls and Biggs
in alright junk and junk
Oh what any [ __ ] face cards in this
deck come on don't like that just I'm so
sick you're not throwing anything you a
fold I fold if I was all you I like all
you guys I'm just telling you what you
should do
fold don't do it doll
Daniel can't help you you're raising it
so now it's 20 it comes a river that's a
that's a burn that's a burn
three four five who's got that six
do you ever coach your kids my game
sports is this like what coaching kids
the thing the whole time you can have
whatever you want it's no limit so the
black tip it's [ __ ] how many of those
are there three or four four all right
so 128 these are two yeah that's the
weirdest bed ever 30:28 what if it's
some kind of source you don't bring your
wallet like a moth comes out that's all
that's 30 30 bucks watch this okay I'm
gonna do earthquake one two there we go
these are fives yeah yeah see that I
can't wait to see what's going on here
all right flip them everybody yeah I got
two pair two pair he's gonna king high
straight three four five hold on I just
want to ask you what Angus do you know
that these cards have to coordinate with
the ones that are on the thing oh yeah
all right [ __ ] let's go to swarm I say
the six man take your [ __ ] shades off
man you can't see anything
the results will be very
different if everyone had what they
thought they had that's the game we
should play do a side yeah why would you
let your guard down with the poker table
I don't I'm always you know what I think
you should let your guard down at a
poker table because like at the end of
the day what's the worst thing that
could happen like you lose some money
and you make some friends I don't if
you're playing with friends you should
probably not be as big a dick as Jay
Larson hey oh no how are you playing
with sticker there's behind his mortgage
as bill you know you got a brand-new
baby needs to make some goddamn money
watch your damn chips in your cars and
everything yes you can at your car down
and psych them out I call you have this
shitty grin every time you say I call ya
what is your interpretation is that a
good poker face yelling [ __ ] and putting
your cards down couldn't believe you won
the [ __ ] is six there man you gotta be
only a relief pitcher man you can't be
thinking about the last hand burn one
and then flip one there's just six
[Laughter]
thanks to you
what do I do you can bet or you could
check you can do a lot of things but you
bet ten bucks
same box no but you got to remember he's
he doesn't know what he was doing since
the start so I would I would go with
that logic all right yeah 20 bucks right
this is different straight vodka huh
straight yeah I got both of them [ __ ]
drunk
look at me sitting with all the chips
all the chips I don't know what I gotta
get with you that sweater get you like a
pipe or something
a lullaby pipe in a good book I love a
great book I'm not losing cuz I'm
drinking I'm drinking because I don't
you boring technique well you just
[ __ ] about with every insult and you
give me some [ __ ] back apparently
thought it was gonna be a meaner table
it's early Morgan it'll
Who I am you know I don't buy into that
at all much more confident in my last
two years you sell it you sound like a
dumb guy who goes you know I'm sorry I'm
very right thanks what's the black
version of who did you change diamonds
to Felipe
[ __ ] I'm out of here like daca what do I
check check Diego yeah you could have
checked like doc all right how much is
it to me 10 bucks hamburger
you [ __ ] produce sitcoms I'm bad at
I've got a fun that's I've gotta find
it's another thing I'm good at and then
you guys have to fill that way I get I
get nervous about remembering rules in
addition to you know banter all right I
call are you using a check yeah or
whatever [ __ ] that we're now a story
then I got a jacket Wow I got two jacks
oh that's your pop god oh that was
enjoyable it's a long game man
I mean it's long I mean halfway through
that one you just flip the table and go
everybody wins I get bored I get bored I
just I actually want to lose my money
just to make an end if I'm sitting with
you and I know that my speed of telling
you to keep moving might frustrate your
get you going I'm gonna keep putting
that fuel in the fire because it just
makes things you know happen I think
poker is a mental game if you want it to
be just don't give a [ __ ] it's like when
your wife is like picking out [ __ ] for
the house you have an opinion for the
first couple of rounds and it's just
like yeah yeah whatever
no but do you like it just why are you
asking me you're just gonna [ __ ] pick
the one you want quit torturing me and
I'm think the best poker player
is the one that you know competitive
through mind games I look for clues and
see as they bluffing on that I got time
for this
I'd like to know what's in the zeitgeist
or does that mean everybody says the
zeitgeist what does that mean it's like
that like runs like what's a Zionist
Zionist it's I guess it would allows
news words you watch the news you I
always mean to look it up and I never do
well would be somebody it would be where
Zion is it'd be somebody who like Morgan
you know what it is don't try to dumb
yourself down to our level just tell
what it is what the [ __ ] is it it's a
Jewish garden right Rudy we're Zionists
I mean this could be really wanna go yes
it's to you I'm so bad at this I mean
like this my power Escobar personation
[Laughter]
[ __ ] somebody could have a 5 6 7 8 9
mm-hmm [ __ ] it all in college drama what
[ __ ] that was smart code that was smart
that was like you know tricky I know but
here's my game well has he been like the
whole time he's had the straight and now
he's just like and was going off [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] cuz he's playing cuz I know he
knows how to play the game I think
you've got so we know how much I think
he's got something good and I think we
should all leave I mean like the hand 20
30 40 80 I believe him 1980 but 82 for
six I believe it was yeah I believe what
are you saying he has he's nothing for
believe on the line so if I was you man
so it would be this is hoping that's
gonna I mean well if he's that good I'd
rather pay to find out I did see a
little handshake honey I don't know
so it's to you 8087 to you if you want
in Jay
and Jase got it I don't I have Kings so
do you have a straighter beat me do you
have an O nope he's got a pair of sevens
oh that feels good cap earthquake it's
been great I'm glad you still have a
giant stack whose money is that come
home he still has his getting bankrolled
by somebody else down the street
reparations why did you do that you just
let him back in the game I wouldn't say
I'm a risk-taking poker player I would
say I'm a risk-taking person who also
plays poker like I think a risk is me
showing up to a hit first tender date
without putting my height on tinder
that's the kind of risk I take I play it
safe and then out that I drink I don't
give a [ __ ] you just have to be willing
to lose your money because if you're not
willing to and then you do you're just
gonna be the worst if you go with 250
bucks just be like alright I'm losing
torn fifty bucks if you leave with 10
that's a win if it's not my money
I take a lot of risk but if it's my
money like that was my money I would
have been I'm out
every time I'm out let me do what I
gotta do put all in suck them all in and
get the money get the [ __ ] I'm out of
here
now how much is blue from your mystery
your mystery stat blew it East Coast
crimped we can just we can make those
whatever value we want I mean did you
know [ __ ] did he get all just reimbursed
here I've been talking about this the
whole game and no one's getting my back
so we're just rolling chips at people
you're a hard guy to like I feel like we
haven't can yeah you lost all
credibility you lost the locker room
that's what happened that's time for you
to move on [ __ ] Jeff George over here
Jay Cutler guy had a cannon man he had a
cannon just could not get along with
other people in the locker room hey you
know when people [ __ ] up an expression
yeah like a stitch in time saves nine i
watch the guy that my wife was watching
some reality show and this guy combined
let sleeping dogs lie and don't beat a
dead horse and they go he goes yeah
these women they they just won't let a
dead horse die what he said they [ __ ]
left it in Isis it
half asleep watching this [ __ ] going a
dead horse died I decided to do the
matter you and you know before you know
what problem you don't let a dead horse
die I kind of like that saying just let
it go you can't let it end it makes
sense cuz it's already dead
what are we doing here everybody's in
everybody's in I like this little
camaraderie at the table duh oh Jesus
duh I used to think he was smart to you
sound effects I'm not even good at the
part that's supposed to make other
people happy which is very do it for you
guys
what's this 2 4 5 10 hey why am I even
doing this math I got to say you're
better at math that I like you're
phenomenal at math are you yes this is
basic math it is alright so how much do
you want to split baby I'm glad three
ways now we got two guys it's not like
[ __ ] calculus can I take that and
divide it by three yes I could with
leftovers yes I think I could handle
that fifth grade level don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
you just said can you divide this up and
divide by we get he's all in with an
extra 12 on top of his 30 so what's that
well I don't know what the other numbers
are I just told you 30 and 12 his 30 his
12 is additional 42 42
so his 30 and 12 is like [ __ ]
phenomenal with math [ __ ] math skills
let's go ace I'll make it 20 all right
another burner won't black chips let's
go get these people in bring all that
stuff back over here black and blue
black and blue the perf will run the
world we need all the knows
can the blue ones be Jewish as a Jew I
feel good you won't have no problem out
of me can you be friends with a white
child that's a time to be friends
anybody if the checks right quick there
every night I fold I got
I got a pair of scissors a pair of
sevens I thought there was another six
in there oh [ __ ] you
I hate when Jay Larson I check I check I
just want to see what everybody else is
gonna [ __ ] doing that I don't
understand how that's legal
when bursts thoughts getting at me late
in the game and I'm doing side pots off
of to all ends and he says I got it I
got it I want to be like you know yeah
I'm good at math dumb people say they're
smart you know I'm good at math I
actually have a really amazing math mind
I could Dave who never said that his
whole [ __ ] life Einstein 33 and 1851
it's just you don't I mean quick numbers
that's all Einstein probably walk draw
and say hey I don't know [ __ ]
J boy sweaters too trying to look
intelligent first of all the sweater
didn't do anything to anyone ber was the
only problem had a problem with a
sweater you could be at a funeral we're
in a nice suit and burro would be
jabbing his brain doesn't stop he just
needs to attack you know he's like a
woodpecker are you in for you're working
today everybody's in you like
I still haven't gone to the Kentucky
Derby I want to go know that my favorite
thing about televised horse racing is
that all the reporters a lot of the
reporters are also on horses you fold
and so you get like this horse at these
reporters who are like who are like
trying to get an interview but they got
like a microphone ah oh God
it's perfect I never watched that I
should've said I Nina oh yeah I lost so
much money there man
I stood it to 2:00 in the morning
bedding and [ __ ] Hong Kong racetracks
shut up really I lost so much money and
you can stay there myself and he starts
showing like races from Hong Kong
Australia oh you said yeah I kind of
like that so wait like the track shut
that goes down racing you could bid on
like oh I'm hard to pronounce the horse
name [ __ ] Chito sold a number five
yes you see the results he probably
knows his favorite horse in Hong Kong he
was like he's got like a favorite get
back in this game all right all right
all right he just six bucks of someone
else literally playing with okay all
right that's a call that's a call that's
hit one and then you go to the turn this
game's over
you can't have that we don't know where
the top was I do I just did it think any
of us really think you do well god damn
it I did there you go comes up to you if
you want to do a reshuffle don't wanna
do no resale I just keep playing cool
cuz why I'm saying if he's gonna get
more upset he then you're gonna
understand that he has some [ __ ] you and
earthquake knows the best shuffle and
the guy who splashed the pot listen I
think you have a situation where his
gourd deal with his car imitating me
yeah hold on a second where are your
cards are Felipe goes if you don't have
no cards I win where are your cards just
going through Wow
what do we do now that'll split the
chips or high are you used to playing
poker do you ever see somebody lose
their hand I've never seen this find six
lost Assante and found a giant stack of
chip man I had two [ __ ] jacks
[Music]
where are they side by side in there are
they side by side there's one Jack no
pair of kings we're together
Queen it doesn't matter
[ __ ] you're full of [ __ ] I back through
this whole game but you've been lying
I'm gonna call this [ __ ] on all this
you have to you have to are we in
agreement or we take this or you know
what we could do go ahead I like you
take it you gonna fist and they take all
my money let's see a millennium there's
consequences to life today was a just a
[ __ ] show just a dumpster fire of hands
then stinking is dirtier is one arm as
bill bromine as vodka in the cloud my
judgment you understand I was doing good
watch the game in the front I was dead
I want to losing no trip No and as Jews
the white man went got the creep of
night the one fundamental rule is don't
lose your cards in your hand so that's
that's a basic win over there got me
something that white liquor didn't have
no here to see then have no roomie none
that are you little brother drink their
name has a rock as a dealer when you
deal you want to believe it's it's
partly you like that what you put on the
table is partly because of you the
dealer has zero control over the cards
yeah they do because I'm telling you
watch the tape it was a [ __ ] six on
there for me to have a straight and I
put all my money up there then the same
disappear
no you're just frustrated you want to
blame somebody so it's like getting mad
at the president like he's not really
running things I really think Trump's
run his stuff with that [ __ ] orange
wig that's just the Illuminati having
fun with you all right now we're going
to 510 so small blind is five biggest
ten minimum bet is ten uncle brother you
know Matthews we're always serving those
are your cards though Oh God
all right so it's the birth this time
forever
quake tend to you to be in with your
makeup wish chips still don't know where
you got those from you just my tomorrow
Felipe come on film this so early I
always want to go to bed it's like 2:00
in the afternoon
I know but losing at poker is like that
feeling we need you
what the [ __ ] does he care I mean wow
the end I'm I'm out I fold fur this
could be it the gentleman 20 I think I
know what he has earthquake come on I
know starting third all right that's
thirty all right all right I call
flipper
oh my god oh nothing nothing nothing
two pairs oh no you have a full house
no he's house of the ten yeah he's got
it he's got it
tens sorry he's got tens and aces he's
got a full house do you mean just three
yeah he's got tens and aces
what will the Terran is this I know it's
not 2 4 6 8 10 aces never seen these why
are you protecting him what is going on
here cuz we on this move is white
[ __ ] that's going on
the white man steal your hand yes here
your deal I've never seen anybody lose
their cards that was like the card
version of the but fumble my life it's
an accidental win like the Buffum of
also the the Mariota the flexion that he
got [ __ ] is going on here
did you watch that dude I'm such a dope
I would literally watch him do that for
20 minutes and I would be like now have
a thought in my head is that earring
glass nose down oh it is okay yeah I
just didn't love the SOP one you don't
feel I feel I can't wear a very
expensive stuff cuz I feel like I'm
gonna lose it
don't you feel like I love one with that
kind of point of view now they're never
got about you [ __ ] and you lose it
you only need ten going all that oh no
you're right you're right let's go to
the flop baby what are we doing
fantastic game it's to Morgan this is
the burglar Morgan bets 20 burr we need
I need you to shut them 30 is that third
yeah perfect you're flush
alright it's a lot of money in that pot
a lot of [ __ ] cards out there
everybody's bluffing I love it oh [ __ ] -
7 para eights wins this alright it goes
to Morgan was all-in at 10 I'm all-in
alright here's 20 I don't want to do
brevis how much 20 so 10 of those are -
yeah that's come on black man you gotta
go to work where we say it's 21 more the
river [ __ ] [ __ ] Morgan can't bet I can't
bet Morgan can bet this game sexist
Morgan you're not allowed to bet why
don't you go back into the kitchen might
make ourselves [ __ ] drink over there
you have no idea how much I'd rather be
in the kitchen right now alright what's
everybody good I got nothing
I got a straight
I have Queens and sevens pair - nope I
got you Queens got you alright that's
fun oh hey good hand Jay I mean whatever
you want to say hey that was fun Jay
thanks for keeping us all know what I
was saying [ __ ] you Jake
Jay Larson is like like a place he's
annoying
Jake I wanted to slap [ __ ] out of
talking [ __ ] to me a whole time like a
supervisor or a principal or a teacher
who really want to hold you back [ __ ]
you know I got a J's chatty which is a
good skill in poker cuz he distracts
okay she looking good look like she hang
with her father she's Jewish
they see you helped me with my career
Morgan Murphy is cool man we other thing
here I think Felipe was baked out of his
mind
sleep is like the guy you bring to like
any home poker game when they say don't
bring anyone who's like not that into
the game like that's who you want to
bring and I wanted him to win the entire
thing I would have lost for him bill is
an [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] bill is a
hard person to say you're wrong too
because he says you're wrong better than
anybody else I think we saw two
different earthquakes today we saw like
a 2.3 which was early on and then he had
a giant thing of vodka and then we got
like a seven eight we got a Northridge
he acted like he didn't understand the
game all of a sudden he had all these
chips well first of all can we [ __ ]
get to the bottom of these chips that
earthquake had what why is no one giving
me an answer
he's the typical white man always got
room Holloway we open that 10 o'clock
that 10:15 mother [ __ ] between 10:00
and 11:00 just the first time I play
poker there's no like baby crying
outside shut up [ __ ] baby down shut
the baby to try to buy baby milk know
that for people with not baby crying you
know Oh where's the listing here in
Spanish somewhere 10 20 30 40 50 okay 65
goddamn goddamn it don't show change me
it doesn't matter one it's not your
money - there's no split Potts no don't
[ __ ] matter 65 it's getting hostile
in here
see I'll be drinking coffee in that
local 65 sure
alright alright now we're going and did
you find a way you burn did you burn
what up oh no that's a barn that's a
burn I had you [ __ ] pieces I had you
you [ __ ] [ __ ] well everyone's all
in so unless mean you want to bet no
that's good I don't have time for my
hand let's go all in J I'm not going on
let's put our friendship on the [ __ ]
line and go all-in I'm gonna fold this
hand on that but you got now you're all
right so you take anyway anyway alright
so you got one more burn and then turn
or look you know what turn this one up
just so people can see what they could
have got you guys could have had a six
but man we got a burn
now you throw the real one just for fun
you know what I mean sighs there you go
so everybody fold it yeah I did
everybody's in everybody's up ace for a
stew so he's got an ace high five six
you got a three fives trip fives over
there I got a pair of fives six eight
five six seven eight nine straight what
[ __ ] five six seven eight nine five six
seven eight nine thank you sir [ __ ]
sitcom deal dude yes and you only played
with eight thousand dollars or more than
anybody else at the table so there's a
table tax yeah 20 40 60 80 120 160
dollars there's a table tax what remove
the table attacks you know keep these
white you want I lost again but I made
some friends I feel so maybe I won
that was my millennial ending I don't
know where earthquake got all those
extra four and $1,000 worth of chips I
mean he was the best player at the table
cuz he had unlimited money you could
just buy pots what do you want when they
said was the last hand it was time for
me to do the old switcheroo so if you
watch real closely you'll see I got all
the goddamn chips
Ramos or look at that slick [ __ ]
you know I'm gonna keep it real man no
matter where I met all I know is that
Jane Larson didn't win
I think burr got worse we did this
before and he still asked do I still
burn then he's flipping he has no idea
are you so focused on being the best
comedian of all time that you can't
learn how to deal sort of money
I think earthquake took off with a prop
money some people say you learn from
losing [ __ ] that
cut rubber learn from winning champagne
I think it rid of Cardiff it's one deed
man you don't use them at department
stores you use karna 420 where it could
mean something like a stripper I want to
be over here with a sad mother Hollis
well it's unless minute [ __ ] that lesson
you give a stripper or Carter 420 she's
dancing a happy man she don't even know
this I ain't get running down the
[ __ ] fake 20 turning her to a peso
give me the W keep the hell for your mom
I wouldn't say necessarily that 11 a.m.
on a Tuesday is my peak me time but at a
blast I love everybody involved and I'm
pregnant
thanks for watching all things comedy
make sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
[Music]